who are the stoic sages this is a great
question and one that definitely
deserves an answer but it's an answer
that I think most people are not going
to be all that happy with once we start
looking into it carefully we see that
this category of sage or wise person
sofos in Greek sapientes in Latin is
going to be a broad one straddling not
just stoic philosophy but we could say
every wisdom tradition intentional way
of living philosophy is a way of life
not just in the Mediterranean
encompassing you know Greek and Romans
or even expanded to the near East but
across the entire world who possesses
wisdom who embodies wisdom who acts and
thinks and chooses and feels in Wise
ways this is a perennial question
and the stoics do in fact have some
answers about this their answers are a
little bit different than many other
people you know there's that proverbial
idea that a sage comes around like a
phoenix once every 500 years they
measure up to this almost unattainable
Summit of human development
the stoics also portray the sages as in
perfect control of their emotions living
completely in accordance with nature
having all of the virtues which includes
not just the cardinal virtues and their
sub-virtues in you know wisdom Justice
Temperance courage but also being some
poticos being a good drinking companion
or being a good party person being
eroticos being a good lover right so
they're they're the perfect human being
they also possess the capacity for
genuine knowledge not the kind of
knowledge that the rest of us have they
have catalyptica Fantasia in Greek right
which is modeled as you know like a fist
closing in on another fist they also
don't just do appropriate actions or
fulfill their duties the things that
they do are entirely good they have the
right motivation unlike the rest of us
rumdoms or Schmucks or as the ancient
Stokes would call us all fools now this
is where we get to a very interesting
peculiarity of the stoic point of view
they often portray the sage or wise
person as if once you cross that
threshold and you're on this side of
wisdom you are a very different kind of
person everybody else is bad everybody
else is foolish everybody else has wrong
ideas everybody else is in some
disharmony with nature the sage alone
actually has it right and you can say
well
how the hell do I make it over there and
this is where a third category very
important for the stoics comes in the
procope toy or proficientes that is
those who are making progress who are
still not sages probably never will be
but are not just foolish people
somewhere in between how do you crush
the threshold into sagehood you got to
work really really hard and you'll
probably not make it but that doesn't
have to dishearten you as Epictetus
himself says I may not become a Socrates
but at least I can become the Epictetus
the best Epictetus that I can be and so
you know this is an important
set of Reflections we should be very
wary of people in the present who talk
about classic stoic figures as if they
were
indeed sages never getting anything
wrong so Epictetus not a sage will tell
you directly that he isn't Marcus
Aurelius great guy not a sage Seneca
definitely not a sage both of them tell
you that that they aren't the sage
mussonius Rufus is not the sage Heracles
is not the sage so who would the stoics
actually consider to have been Sages
there's two legendary people that come
up quite a bit both of whom might seem a
little bit strange to us in the present
one of them is Heracles or Hercules who
is also viewed as a representative
person by the cynics who of course you
know feed into the stoic philosophy
um they're regarded as he's regarded as
a good person who used his strength to
you know undo Injustice and impose
Justice he winds up being deified being
made one of the Olympian gods eventually
so that kind of makes sense and then
there's Odysseus
who you know he's kind of a Wily tricky
guy lies on a lot of occasions and cages
in ruses he is bold he is courageous he
is also considered to be one of the
wiser of the Greeks Mentor perhaps gives
better counsel than
Odysseus but Odysseus is pretty darn
close those are legendary people who
would actually be included among the
potential sages from you know we could
say living history well Seneca says that
Cato was the closest thing that he ever
saw Cato the younger military commander
stoic practitioner so you know he's a
good representative if you don't know
the story of Cato he uh among many other
things fought in the Civil War against
Julius Caesar reluctantly joining the
side of Pompeii and the Senate because
they were the lesser of two evils but
you know commanding his troops as he
ought to and then committing suicide
afterwards so he couldn't be used as a
propaganda tool by the Victorious Caesar
two other people who come up quite
frequently Socrates the great
philosopher understood by the stoics not
primarily through Plato but more through
xenophon and then you know oral
Traditions probably about Socrates
diogenes the cynic who came from sunope
to Athens
acted like kind of a goofy person but
was engaged in trying to uh like
Socrates draw his fellow citizens
towards virtue they're sometimes viewed
by the stoics as being sages with what
we know about them you know sometimes
that might be a little questionable
Epictetus actually has something very
interesting to say about
Socrates diogenes and Zeno the founder
of stoicism he tells us that each of
them did what they ought to do each of
them served the Gods
by doing different things Socrates went
around and asked people questions
pointed questions right uh diogenes went
around and haranged people got in their
face and said the life you're living is
crap you need to act in a different way
Zeno is much more sedate and calm and
taught people and it's it's kind of
intimated that the sage would take on
different roles depending on you know
what kind of situation they're in
um was Xeno a sage Zeno doesn't say that
he's a sage in anything that we have in
any of the fragments
um there's some you know tradition that
Zeno and his successor cleanthus may
have considered themselves sages but
that crucifus explicitly denies that he
is a sage it's this is all rather
dubious and I think we can say that
while the ancient stoics thought that
Xeno clanthase crucipus and the other
skolarx diogenes Auntie Potter were good
people and working on themselves they
were not yet sages so we don't really
have a lot of examples of stoic sages
and we should think to ourselves well
what do we want in asking who are the
sages what are we trying to get is it
merely an ideal that we need to work
towards it's nice to have like a goal
post a benchmark even if it's completely
unattainable for us it kind of inspires
us to go after it that might work for
some people we can also ask you know are
there sages we don't know about or could
there be sages all around us that are
doing a great job and we just don't know
that they're sages there's even a
discussion whether the sage will know
that he or she is a sage or not that
runs throughout some of the stoic
literature
um we should you know say
they could be at best Role Models should
we accept them as Role Models should we
think of whoever we count as a stoic
Sage as in some way like being a teacher
for us if we think of Socrates for
example as a sage can we do as Marcus
suggests that we you know approach
situations and ask well what would
Socrates say about this situation what
would he say about my behavior in it
um that might be useful there is in fact
a practice that's been developed by
modern stoics basically imagining
yourself in the presence of a sage who's
watching you now the sage of course
wouldn't get ticked off with you and you
know say I'm going to punish you for
being bad or anything they might not
even feel pity or compassion a Laos in
Greek towards you but they could at
least say wow man you're screwing up
here's how you could do better so the
long and short answer of this is there's
a lot of candidates for being sages we
know quite a bit about what the stoics
think of sage hypothetically would
feel like think like behave like talk
like but we don't have a lot of people
who we can point to and say that's
definitively a stoic Sage we have at
best candidates that are looked to by
many people within classic and modern
stoicism as having been Sages